Jakob's into the channel i'm ryan right
I'm dead yeah we're gonna watch the
trailer day for what are we watching the
trailer no reward pyro warrior yeah what
is this dad
this is mixing the wonderful world of
Zelda though with the wonderful world of
dynasty warriors Sam smash together and
what I'm hoping is going to be a
fantastic hack and slash you're gonna
kill so many goblins so it's an actual
crossover game it's more of the dynasty
Warriors format with a Zelda skin to it
okay yes finish each other's sentences
the childhood friends why they do that
weird so which one of you is the guy
that gets girls that would definitely be
a that Seibert yeah me yeah cuz I was
gonna see you see best friends love each
other
Oh
Kendall
she got the interesting yeah sandwich
probably multiplayer yeah it should it
lead me to Blair who should call this
game like [ __ ] them up carnage that we
decide what like a minute 30 is yes it's
like watching like elf transformers the
whole time no it's not crazy do you
they were just had like new ways of
demolishing the graphics everything was
cool yeah I want to play that that's a
super smash kind of feel about it yeah
it's definitely got this like it's so
funny cause like the trailer starts with
like this very like Zelda sort of like
here's the lore of everything that
happened before then just suddenly the
rocket oh I love dynasty Warriors with
like all of my heart and so this just
kind of mixes like two worlds that I
love so much I just hope I'm hoping that
it's just enough to just make me feel
like the most incredible person ever is
it kill everything do you uh do any of
you guys think that Zelda is pretty
attractive yeah yeah I think his elders
like really attractive like I would do
things you know she's a princess
you know she's got the cash here a few
times first time I treat women welcome
to the real region well what more can
you say it looks like a great [ __ ] up
game if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe right here and if you want
to subscribe dance channel you can
subscribe right here and he doesn't have
a channel
now well you got my channel donate money
to the Air Force
maybe the taxes he continues to have a
job Margo Robinson hello
might be a girl sup baby already already
know you look like or how old you are
I'm gonna hit on you
Ryan you're hilarious love your videos
plus give me a shout-out yes you can get
a shout-out Marta you're beautiful
remember that I'll grab it out of the
shadow or handsome introduce ya if
you're a dude I'm hoping you're not
chained if you are cool you're an
awesome guy good job but if you're a
girl hell yeah baby I'm the age first no
I don't believe in age oh yeah I think
that'll get you into a lot of trouble
buddy I should probably edit this Joseph
he said what's up real rejects that's
heavy sounds I love your guys channel
the reviews are hilarious and the
trailer reactions are awesome and if
it's not too much of a hassle can you
guys give me a shout-out please and
thank you love you guys well it kind of
is a hassle sometimes so come up with
new things to say to every person it
takes oxygen and that's really what it
comes down to so it's a hassle but yeah
man good we'll give you a shout-out
Joseph ah shout-out to you mother [ __ ]
Oh
I'm clapping for Joseph that's great
yeah yeah that's good that's good yeah
people I think people will like this
video
yeah maybe even leave a like yeah maybe
they you leave a like or like subscribe
and maybe tell their friends about it
yeah
share it like our social network you
know like if they had three friends that
they had come here and then they or
three friends that came here